19 right now whoops throw it down
here go to fight point lead for history
[Applause]
the level of commitment that this guy is
shown let me shut up
[Applause]
sales rate over six it's gonna take
advisor Lakers I can't
[Applause]
by the statute he'll get a free that his
sexy years leblanc leblanc for the time
[Applause]
they play period without question
[Applause]
[Music]
to scoring to get in that time being
used on the glass you see the reach I'm
talking about that is incredible
[Applause]
certainly can this dress he wasn't gonna
be able to block the shot started by the
Angelo keep playing recognition that's
right by the young fella throwing the
ball look the beautiful open when the
Lakers are at their
[Applause]
20 or 25 games but he's played in all 13
games in March he's back right down the
middle depth Dajjal spins
[Applause]
he's got a V on the trail do you believe
that one Sean Tuohy
made three really taboos going at a
challenger Dellavedova and the Cavs and
Clarkson met up top 18 again Kevin
closed the final two minutes a be up
against Olynyk who flops Hamrick he will
stop gender the drug gonna sweat he's
been at the table for about a minute
have now ad on the crossover far too
whole and the people are very similar
[Applause]
Davis past oh wow so he still got game
holiday sets it up her bottle one-on-one
eighty between his legs
all the way to the cup
don't try that at all he collected at
just miss of the night he made his first
5 lob for Davis one-handed stuff